hey everybody
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report direct message for february 11
2021 and we're doing an ask me anything
q a
you guys have submitted your questions
at reubenreport.locals.com
that is my on locals community free
of bots trolls and other psychos
so do join us there if you haven't and
i'm going to try to go as quickly as
possible because
we got a ton of questions and i won't
belabor the point here we go
robert asks platforms like locals are
providing a space for commentators and
pundits
but any movement needs those who speak
to the soul not just the mind i do agree
with that
how can we support and cultivate our own
poets artists musicians
architects etc i love this question so
one of the things that we're doing with
locals
right now we're building digital homes
for creators i don't care what kind of
creator you are
most of the people on locals the high
profile people say like scott adams and
tulsi gabbard and
greg gutfeld and judge jeanine people
like that are sort of in the political
world
that's absolutely true that just is
because i'm in the political world and
i've been promoting this
thing so my network of people happen to
be more in the political world
but you're absolutely right i think one
of the problems we're having with
society right now
is that we don't talk about art and
music and
architecture and all of the things of
beauty so one of the interesting things
is in my community most people have been
brought together through politics but we
do
talk about food and wine of course and
what people are listening to and i post
music that i'm listening to
and you know people post spotify
playlists and all that kinds of stuff
but ultimately what i want locals to
have is many different verticals so
it'll not just
have people that are in the politics
world but we're working on right now are
onboarding some people that are big in
the sports world and i would love to go
more into the music world and the art
world and the fashion world
and the gaming world and everything else
we haven't put a dime into
into pr everything that we've built
basically has come from my network so
that's been a sort of limiting factor so
far but the company's doing really well
we've
raised a nice amount of money and it's
and it's going to go and continue but i
also think something that's very cool
is that you know if you come for
politics you might find out that there's
a lot of other stuff
that's there that's interesting and i
would hope that that would be a little
less of the case like if you
if you sign on to an artist hopefully
not everything would become political
there but if you go to a political
person maybe
you would find out more about a whole
bunch of other stuff the problem is when
things that aren't supposed to be
politicized
become endlessly politicized uh
stephanie says what do we tell our kids
when they ask us what's wrong with the
world mine are 13
and 16. um you know i don't have kids
yet so
i can't sit here and pretend that i'm a
parent and i can only imagine what it's
like
particularly in this last crazy year to
have
you know peop children of that age 16
and 13 who are really trying to like
figure out what they think of the world
uh compare their thoughts and feelings
and the stuff that they're learning
versus the world as it is
to see so many adults that seemingly are
crazy and so people
so many people afraid of their own
shadow and all of that stuff
i don't know how um how you'd
parent in a responsible way but the best
i think i can say is
to your question which is what do we
tell our kids when they ask us what's
wrong with the world
i would say we've let bad ideas
in because we're afraid of standing up
for ourselves i
i think that's what all of this boils
down to all of the ideas
of wokism and collectivism and
the the modern racism that is being
ushered in under the guise of
anti-racism
it's all bad ideas that we've defeated
in the past we've defeated
collectivist movements like communism
and socialism we've defeated them and
then
and then in our success we kind of grew
fat
the freedoms that we have grew fat and
and liberalism in a way grew
grew kind of fat and the soft underbelly
of tolerance which is such an important
part of liberalism was taken advantage
of
by by the workstars and the best thing
that you can do
i think i think and again i'm not a
parent of
a 13 year old and a 16 year old but i
think the best thing you can do is show
them that you're kind of brave that you
fight for
whatever it is you believe and you you
know in this case perhaps
part of you doing that is that you
support me on locals and it's like maybe
i'm out there doing some of those things
but whatever it is in your own life
to show them you have to map i suppose
for them a world that
is a world that you want to create so
that hopefully they'll do it for
themselves
um i i think that i think that kind of
works
uh dragon hawk asks do we get
more great beach pictures of you and
david janet from florida
we shall see you know you got to give
the people what they want i have not
as you know i'm focused on locals i'm
not doing it only fans although we've
gotten some requests
and i probably make a hell of a lot more
money god only knows why
uh but perhaps there will be some
pictures i i am actually technically
people to be totally honest with you
as you're watching this video right now
i am in florida at the moment we
pre-taped this two days ago so
technically today's tuesday you're
watching it on thursday i'm probably on
the beach
right now hopefully not on twitter and
perhaps posting beach pictures
the only way you're going to find out
though is to check out
reubenreport.locals.com
what are your plans for valentine's day
do you celebrate so we usually try to
do a week in florida right around now
right around president's day which often
lines up
president's week president's day which
often lines up around valentine's day so
we're usually in florida
so most likely i will be eating
swordfish
or grouper or some other delicious fish
and we'll have some wine and we'll just
like have a really pleasant night and
that really is it i'm a romantic guy
365 days a year so we don't need
valentine's day all the time you know
what i mean
uh let's see i want to just jump to a
couple others here that i want to bump
around
uh the pragmatist says any further
thoughts
on libertarianism's contribution to our
current problem and what we can do about
adapting it
to be a significant part of the solution
so there's a really ongoing debate right
now within the libertarian movement
do we focus all of our energies on the
libertarian party which is an
abject mess and you got naked people
running on the stage and terrible
candidates that they've put up over the
last couple years
and they don't do anything down ticket
they save it all for the presidency and
then the mainstream ignores them
and the litany of problems that you know
that the party has
and the question is do you put all of
your energy to fixing that
structure because it is on the ballot in
most of the states and there is some
base there
or do you focus on sort of
making the conservatives a bit more
libertarian
to me just to me personally that's the
sensible one that's one of the things
that i've tried to do i think i'm
actually
doing it quite well uh and i've been
able to take my conservative
friends and show them that they can be a
little more okay with something
like gay marriage that maybe isn't
necessarily within their religious
belief
um that's like some way of doing it like
showing the republicans hey don't just
talk about
lowering taxes actually do it don't just
talk about lowering regulation
actually do it these were some of the
reasons that i ended up becoming
obviously okay with trump because he was
doing those things right
so even if you think about it from trump
the guy who had more energy
and more media focus and everything
before they decided to
to de-person him it's like he could have
run as a third-party candidate right and
what would have happened we would have
ended up
with a democratic president i'm talking
about in 2016.
like if trump had been like okay i'm
gonna run as the third party guy because
i'm mostly a third party guy
and then it's a republican and me and
clinton well obviously clinton
would have won so trump said okay i'm a
business guy
and he was a little more on the
libertarian side he didn't go to wars
right like that's big for libertarians
so i think he modified the republican
party in a way that's to me the more
sensible approach but i could see
how you would argue it either way and
i'm completely down for those debates i
think i'm going to go on a couple
libertarian podcasts
to discuss that with a bunch of people
let's see
uh in pieces total fun just out of the
box no politics after
an after dinner game scrabble or yahtzee
definitely scrabble
love the scrabble used to play scrabble
with my grandma she crushed me all the
time
i i do love scrabble uh bring a bottle
of cab or red blend
uh probably depends what we ate but this
is after
dinner so after dinner i could go for a
blend so that's maybe a little lighter
than a cab if you want a really great uh
red blend
it's a little on the pricey side usually
around 40 bucks a bottle but the
prisoner red blend is
is pretty spectacular a late-night snack
of uh almonds or walnuts
almonds or i do you know just you give
me just a simple
uh almond you don't even have to salt it
just a simple almond
i enjoy chewing it they're they're
crispy and then you get that that chew
sensation i enjoy
the almond uh gadget6 usa
says was politics ever really based on
facts
i think politics has mostly been based
on emotional needs
and this and thus responded to in that
way i've never bought into the facts
don't care about your feelings
as is often stated by bench period you
know it's really interesting over the
last couple days i've been
uh showing you guys these clips of
ronald reagan on
johnny carson tonight show and you can
see he's he's an
incredible incredible communicator of
ideas
and someone who clearly knows what he's
talking about uh and he's also
doing facts right you could take someone
like thomas soule
an incredible communicator of ideas even
now at like 91 he still is but when you
watch seoul watch some videos you can
find them on youtube i watch them all
the time
of seoul like 30 years ago uh and you
will see just a
fabulous you know prime peak of his life
communicator of ideas
but also an excellent communicator of
facts i think we've run into a strange
time that
facts sort of don't matter for several
reasons i mean facts kind of don't
matter because everyone just picks what
facts they like
and then just runs with their narrative
so that makes facts
less important in a certain sense right
not
not in the truest sense but in a certain
sense but then i think the other thing
is that because of social media where
everything is on oh my god did i get the
retweet did i get the like
well then you're going to do that with
the motion you're going to do that with
owning the libtard or crushing the
conservac or whatever
the freaking stupid phrases are and that
then
becomes the more important game sort of
than what is
factual so ben is right facts don't care
about your feelings
the question is are we governed by facts
anymore or are we governed by feelings i
would say in many cases in most cases
especially now where we care about
equity instead of equality
well then it's about feelings it's like
oh it feels right to have an
equal amount of people who look like a
certain something have equal amount
of representation at this job or at this
school or something
and it's like well is that factually the
best way to build the best business or
have the highest level of education or
anything else
of course the answer is no but it feels
right to a lot of people and that that
is a bit of a dangerous thing
steamboat says from a psychological
standpoint what do you believe the
perceived reward
is for those who subscribe to the woke
agenda do you think this is all for
intrinsic feel goods or is there
something more they hope to achieve
i mean i've talked a lot about this at
some level and i'm by the way i have
jordan peterson on the show in a couple
weeks and we will
we will dive into this because this is
exactly what he was warning
about and i'm obviously super psyched to
talk to jordan again it's been great
that he's
you know making his his little foray
back into the
into the fight he's got the new book
coming out and all that stuff so what is
it that these people get
is a great question what do the what do
the woke people get well first off i
think you get a tremendous amount of
control
right like people none of us can control
the world right you may want to control
the world the tears for fear song right
everybody wants to
everybody wants to rule the world well i
don't know that exactly i want to rule
the world
i'm sort of more of a realist and that i
see the world as it is and if i can do a
little something to
make it a little more in line with the
way i think then then that's great but i
i don't really want to control the world
or rule the world or anything else
i think a lot of people feel really out
of control and once you realize that you
can get a lot of people to be quiet or
to bow to you
or to give you money because you're woke
that you can use some crudgel against
them to get them to behave as you want
you kind of feel like a god
you kind of do and i think that they've
tricked a lot of
otherwise smart sensible people into
thinking
that if they speak up they're going to
be destroyed and by the way a lot of
them do get destroyed when they speak up
but but the only solution is for more
people to
speak up but i think psychologically
it's about controlling the world
i think it also has something to do with
the god-shaped whole you know it's not a
coincidence
uh that most of the woke people are
are non-believers to some extent it's
like belief
i've come to the belief that belief is
so intrinsic to being a human
that if you fully say i'm not a believer
you you in some ways have to find
something else to believe in
ironically and what they've found is
this all-encompassing woke agenda that
you're talking about
and then once you believe in that then
you'll probably do a lot of other things
to make people bow to it
it's it's scary and dangerous but we got
we gotta fight it um oh i like this
question
this is from jenny she says what advice
would you have for someone who has lost
every friend and family member through
this nonsense it's hard
not to be on an island when coveted
restrictions prevent real life
interaction
locals has helped with that so thank you
so first off one of the reasons that i'm
so thrilled with the locals community is
that you know we've done some dinners
together we've done some movie nights
and we are creating locals
we're creating a local community uh and
i met people
actual people at a bar in dallas about
40 people showed up and i may do one in
florida and i'll start doing them in la
too
because we need to rethink community and
we need all that uh well first off
um you know if you've lost all these
friends and family members i'm
sorry like i feel it i i hear you i know
how many people are going through this i
have
my own versions of this going on uh
right now and it is not easy
um but i think you know the only answer
that i can give you that'll make any
sense is that it's better
this way than the other way if the other
way means just have
people around you who will not know what
you really think who
you will never tell uh what you're
actually feeling and what is important
to you and all of those things well
that's just a slow death right like
that's just sort of the frog in the pot
death and
just one day you won't even remember the
person that you were 20 years ago
because you've just you've just slowly
whittled it away
the fact that your friends or family
whether whether they
still consider you friends or not the
fact that they know what you believe
well then it's on them to maybe practice
a little tolerance practice a little
decency but you've stood up for what you
believe
and i promise you you will find more
friends um
you know one of the things that's kept
me sane in this i've lost a lot of
friends in the midst of this
right like and especially since i came
back from the summer and then i
officially announced that i was going to
support trump like
trust me i lost a lot of friends um one
of the things that have kept me sane is
that my two best friends i've said this
a couple times from childhood
one of them i met the first day in
kindergarten uh
my buddy john and i remember meeting him
first day of kindergarten and now it's
40 years later and then our buddy irie
moved to town in third grade
we just saw each other in dallas for the
first time in 10 years the
first time that the three of us were
together but i have a text chain going
with them all the time and i think if
you can find some old people from your
life to connect with
that that helps you sort of stay sane
like that person newbie
knew me way back when there's something
to that but i promise you you will find
you will find new friends and if the
locals community has done anything to be
part of that i think that's just awesome
um chris says dave there's already
speculation that governor ron desantis
will run
in for president in 2024 what are your
thoughts i think that would be great
i think he's the best governor in the
united states right now
i think he's done a great job in letting
people make decisions for themselves i
think we've
seen that by opening up the state and
letting businesses do what they think is
right
that he's actually kept covid numbers
down you know florida has the second
oldest population so you would have
thought oh we're going to keep this
state open
with all of these old people you would
have thought that the numbers would be
not
double triple quadruple california or
new york you'd think they would be
exponentially higher right because
we're not doing any of the good things
that they tell us to do in new york or
california
and yet they're not their numbers are
lower i think it's possible that they've
gotten to hurt immunity faster and that
and
more important that whether there are
some mistakes along the way there
his intuition as a human being was to
let people make decisions for themselves
uh so as i taped this on tuesday even
though it's thursday
and i'm in florida as i say this right
now i'm going to
be sitting at a restaurant eating with
people as is our god-given right
at least for now um so i think he's just
done a great job i would absolutely
support him i think that would be
awesome and by the way
he's mapping out for other people how to
be brave
right like he's mapping out for other
politicians yeah you're going to have to
stand up to the mob and they're going to
write hip pieces about you and they're
going to say mean things
about you but if you got into this game
of politics it's a messy game and
and fight man fight uh let's see
um sarah says how do we get democratic
governors to vaccinate our elderly
citizens
after they are after they terrified
everyone into submission last year
i think this is another one of the
issues people are now afraid to go out
so how do you vaccinate all of these old
people and you've got people waiting on
lines in the cold and all of these
things i guess we could do more mobile
vaccinations
um there's probably like a whole series
of ways to do all these things
but but your question really gets to
just like the heart of fear thing
and i think a lot of people are feel
fearful right now i think
a good portion of that is warranted like
there is
a pandemic i'm not sitting here telling
you that there isn't a pandemic
we're also 11 months off of two weeks
to flatten the curve um but there's also
economic problems people are
people are more depressed i'm actually
super interested and i need to do
more shows on this um i'm super
interested
in the the psychological damage that has
been done like
to all of us like even me things have
been pretty good here my business
is is online like we've been able to
expand
i s you know locals is going really well
like i've been able to succeed here
um and do the show this way which
actually by doing it this way instead of
always in person with guests
it actually cut down on some of our
costs it made us a slimmer trimmer
operation like that's all good but i
know there's been a psychological toll
on me too like all of us sitting around
going man
is is the world ever gonna get better is
that anyone gonna save us is anyone
gonna fix this
um just having to constantly worry about
that where if you think back to last
february
you weren't worried about that you just
oh the world kind of exists there are
some problems
there's an orange man as president of
the united states but everything's going
to be okay
where now it's like we i think most of
us are like
whoa what does the future look like and
and by the way
that's being put into action as we know
people are fleeing blue states like
crazy and moving to red states
and people are thinking about all sorts
of things whether you what kind of job
do you want and
and i don't have to commute anymore do i
need a bigger house because i need an
office and can i
do am i married to the right person do i
like my family like a whole
series i would say of like massively
existential issues
for us all to think about uh which is uh
which is a
super interesting spot to be in it's
scary but it's also inspiring in a way
and i think
we will get through this and and there
are businesses to be built there are
institutions to be built there are
education systems to be built
and it ain't going to be easy but if it
was easy everyone would do it
pseudomoniker says obi-wan said only a
sith
deals in absolutes does that mean
obi-wan is a sith
great question it's a question that has
been debated by
jedi and sith alike for years and years
and years
it is it is an absolute statement only a
sith
deals in absolutes does that mean
obi-wan is
it by his own definition yes i'm going
to give obi-wan a little bit of a leash
here because it was an extremely
stressful day i mean think about what he
went through that day
not only did his padawan just wipe out
you know
half the jedi order and slaughtered
everybody but then he had to get on that
long flight to mustafar
he then saw her you know he saw him uh
choke padme it was hot there he's
wearing this big robe
so i think if he just got a little lost
in the language i think that's okay
although as jordan peterson would say
you know be careful
with the words that you choose so he
should have been a little more careful
but everything being equal all to death
and then that hot cotton outfit while
standing in on a lava planet it's just a
lot to deal with
um jayvenord says
what are some things you are thankful
for from 2020
um well i'm super thankful for you guys
i mean i think that
really would be the number one thing
like you guys
enabled me to continue doing this show
and and be independent and
communicating with so many of you in the
in the community you know the first
thing i do when i i try not to have my
phone in my room as you know
but when i wake up in the morning uh the
first thing i do once i'm online
i usually have some water and some
coffee to start the day i kind of
stretch out the neck
i let clyde out but when i do open up
the phone i jump in the community first
and i see like a whole bunch of good
stuff kind of what you guys are talking
about and that actually does help me
frame things right because i've seen
so many people who i used to really
respect hold in really high regard many
people that were on my show
that i feel like have have totally lost
the plot so when i see
like what i would say are regular people
and i don't mean that to be disparaging
i mean that in the best
possible sense i'm just a regular person
when i see just like regular decent
people coming together and talking about
things differently and sort of
you know and the funny stuff sharing
memes and all that i'm very appreciative
that like
i've been able to cultivate some decent
people in the world because i think
that's what people are missing you know
there's a reason we called it
locals.com like i think people are
missing the local thing and we used to
think about the local community as oh
the four blocks that live around you
right or you just like your local town
or whatever but but we need the local
thing
online as well um
let's see i'll do uh what do they tell
me two more here two more real quick
uh formerly alph says when california
opens back up completely if that ever
happens again
what's the first thing you'll do you
know what's funny is in the last year
you guys have seen i post these like
crazy
tomahawk steaks that i'm making and all
this wagyu stuff and all that and i love
love love grilling i've always liked
grilling but in the last year
from the lockdown i have learned to love
grilling i love knowing what the
different cuts of meat are
doing a tomahawk doing a porterhouse
doing a tri-tip
doing filets like i just love it and and
figuring out what i'm doing on the
seasoning side and learning all of it i
i absolutely love it
that being said i do miss going to a
restaurant every now and again when i
was in dallas i went to a great uh
a great steak joint i think it was
called it might have been called
charlie or something it's a curtis stone
restaurant in dallas can you google that
real quick
it was it was a great restaurant but the
one thing i do there's a restaurant here
in l.a called boa on
sunset strip and they just it's got
great ambiance and it's sort of indoor
outdoor and the lighting's cool and
you know it's a little bit of celebrity
but not in like the horrible celebrity
way
and i think i've actually mentioned it
on the show once before
um no not delta charlie's in dallas
curtis stone restaurant in dallas can
you just google that um i think i
mentioned this once before but that that
famous picture that went viral a couple
years ago when the whole idw crew had
dinner together in la
when uh it was rogan and sam harris and
jordan
and eric weinstein and shapiro and me
and was anyone else there maybe maybe
someone else was there
that was at uh that was at boa's takeout
so i do miss that
oh the steakhouse that i'm talking about
in in dallas which was fantastic that i
was out last week was georgie
by curtis stone uh just amazing it's an
australian steakhouse was just
phenomenal
and one more question for you fine
people
um what do i want to do here scroll
quick i'm just going to pick something
okay let's oh well this seems like a
fitting one to end on uh timothy says
dave you've recently
uh started to say that you believe in a
god do in part with your time
with jordan peterson can you elaborate a
little further
uh if you've been diving deeper into any
particular religions
so look i've been talking about this a
lot lately i just find belief
at least at this point in my life at 44
years old relative to everything
happening in the world
i find no way around belief
it's an odd way to say that you're a
believer i suppose or
an odd way to say you've made the leap
of faith that is what you have to do as
a as a rational person
at some point you could say okay i think
this i think this i think this
but the reason they call it a leap of
faith is because at some point then you
have to make the jump to say okay
i believe like and that that as a i
think as a
someone that puts so much emphasis on
intellect and logic and learning i think
that's been a very difficult thing
for for me personally i mean i can say
this i
i also know that in the last couple
years of just traveling around and
meeting people and everything else like
the people that i've met and this is
of course it's not absolutely um without
exception
but the people that i've met that
generally come from
a community of believers or have some
set of belief
generally seem to be nicer calmer um
more more giving funnier happier
all of those things um and i think the
proof is in the pudding as you may
remember there was a really
uh vocal sort of growing powerful
movement
of of atheists a couple years ago
and i even spoke at the reason rally in
dc at the mall like i
like like forrest gump i spoke at that
thing remember
forrest gump and then she jumps out into
the pond i spoke there uh
about it and i was actually calling out
social justice this is probably like six
or seven years ago at this point i was
calling out social justice
and saying we have to be better i was a
lefty at the time um because i could see
the beginnings of how it was all falling
apart because
of social justice and it basically
collapsed under that and i think in a
time
when there's such chaos like
for me at least you know john kasich i
can't believe i'm going to quote john
kasich
while talking about faith but when i had
john kasich on he said something very
interesting about faith
he said a lot of people can do it with
without god i'm not one of those people
and i thought that there was something
very humbling and decent about that and
i think i've come to a similar
conclusion
um obviously i'm i'm jewish so that has
more to i believe in something that is
similar to what my father believed which
is what my grandfather believed and my
ancestors
believed and that is the strange thing
about belief if you're if you're
christian you happen to be born into
christianity usually
and then you believe a certain set of
things but that's not the part the
whittling around the difference between
what you know someone believes as
as a jew or a christian or whatever
denomination you might be that's not the
important thing to me at least right
now the important thing to me right now
is it's it's sort of a starting off
point
to build a better society and again as i
always say look i've got a lot of
friends who are atheists
they're deeply moral decent good people
and i think it can work at the micro
level i don't think it can work at the
macro level i think that's why society
is so whacked right now
i really do so uh i'll i'll keep talking
about this i appreciate the question
and i think if we did all talk about
this in a little more of an honest way
that maybe we could get out of some of
this stuff
uh guys tomorrow we are back with a big
panel show on friday we're going to be
talking about censorship from a medical
perspective and a legal perspective
and i've got dr drew who needs no
introduction i think you guys know dr
drew
i've also got dr zubin damania uh who's
a really
interesting guy right now who's been
censored a bunch of times dr drew's been
censored a bunch of times
while trying to have honest debates
about covet and lockdown and everything
else
uh and then uh lawyer viva fry who's
also blowing up right now who's a really
interesting voice
uh reminder that my interview with ion
hersey ali
is already up at reubenreport.locals.com
for the full thing you can get part two
right here on
youtube right now thank you have a nice
weekend
and i'll be on the beach adios